so what I'm going to talk about here is
this is a power station so if you've
ever wondered what a couple of million
horsepower looked like that's pretty
much what it looks like and for me it's
always been about the rocket in fact so
much so that when I was growing up the
school called in my parents to to the to
the Y a bit of a discussion because they
believe that my aspirations were
unrealistic for what I wanted to do and
they suggested that I take up a job at
the local elementary melter because I
was very good with my hands but for me
aluminium or as you Canadians say
aluminum was not part of my plan at all
so I started building rockets when I was
at school they got bigger and bigger I
actually hold an unofficial land speed
record for a rocket bike and
rollerblades while wearing a rocket pack
but as the Rockets got larger and larger
and more and more complex I started to
be able to think I could do something
with this now today we we hear about
very large rockets you know taking
humans to or aspiring to take humans to
the moon and Mars and beyond and
that'sthat's really important but
there's a revolution going on in the
space industry and it's not a revolution
of the big it's a revolution of the
small so here we have an average to
large size spacecraft in 1990 we can
tell it's 1990 because of the
powder-blue smocks were all the trend in
the clean rooms in 1990 but there was
your average to live sized spacecraft in
1990 here's a spacecraft that's going to
launch this year this particular
spacecraft has four high resolution
cameras a whole lot of sensors a
communication system we're gonna launch
thousands of these into the solar system
to look for extraterrestrial life quite
different you see that Moore's law
really applied itself to spacecraft
however the Rockets that we've been
building have been you know designed for
carrying these very large school bus
sized space craft store but but this
kind of launch vehicle here is is not
very not very practical for launching
something that will fit on the you know
the tip of my finger
in fact to give you a sense of scale
here this rocket is so large that I
inserted a picture of myself and my
underpants and complete confidence
knowing that you will not be able to
find me
it's how big this rocket actually is
moving on so this is our air rocket it's
called the electron it's a small launch
vehicle for lifting these small payloads
into orbit and we that the key here is
not the size of the rocket the key here
is frequency if you actually want to
democratize space and enable access to
space launch frequency is the absolute
most important thing out of all of this
now I always say that in order to really
democratize space there's three things
you have to do then each one of these
three things has kind of the equivalent
amount of work so the first is obviously
you have to build a rocket that's
obvious
the second is regulatory and the third
is infrastructure so let's talk a little
bit about infrastructure so this is our
launch site it's obviously not Cape
Canaveral but it's a little launch site
in fact it's the only private orbital
launch site in the entire world down in
New Zealand and you may think that's a
bit of an odd place to to build a rocket
company and build a launch site but the
thing is that every time you launch a
rocket you have to close down around
about 2,000 kilometers of airspace 2,000
kilometers of marine and shipping space
and ironically it's one of the things in
America that doesn't scale very well
because every time you close down all
that airspace you disrupt all these
travelers Jim's trying to get to the
destination the airlines really hate
rocket companies because it costs them
around about $70,000 a minute and so on
so what you really need if you want to
truly have rapid access to space is in
reliable and frequent access to space is
you need basically a small island nation
in the middle of nowhere with no
neighbors and no air traffic and that
just happened to be in New Zealand so
that's kind of the the infrastructure
bit now the next bit of that is
regulatory so believe it or not New
Zealand is not known for its space
prowess or at least wasn't and you can't
just rock on up to a country with what
is essentially considered an ICBM
because unfortunately if you can put a
satellite into orbit you can use that
rocket for doing
significantly nasty things so quickly
you run afoul of a whole lot of rules
and regulations and international you
know treaties of you know the
non-proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction and whatnot so it becomes
quite complex so if in order for us to
launch down in New Zealand we had to get
you know the United States government
and the New Zealand government to agree
to sign a bilateral treaty and then once
that bilateral treaty was signed to you
know safeguard the technology the New
Zealand government had a whole lot of
obligations and they had to create a
whole lot of rules and regulations in
fact the head to pass laws through
Select Committee and through Parliament
ultimately and into complete laws and
then once you have laws you need
somebody who administers them so they
had to create a Space Agency and then
once they created a Space Agency the
Aziz felt left out so they had to create
a Space Agency and on and on and on it
goes so you see there's a massive
portion of this in fact 2/3 of it that
does not even involve the rocket and
let's talk about the rocket so if you're
going to launch you know what I didn't
say is that launch site we actually
license to launch every 72 hours for the
next 30 years so we have more launch
availability as a private company than
America does as an entire country and if
you got to launch every 72 hours then
that means you have to build a rocket
every 72 hours and unfortunately there's
no such thing as just a one stop rocket
shop you can't go and buy bits to build
a rocket every rocket is absolutely
bespoke every component is that
absolutely bespoke and you're in a
constant battle with physics every day
every single day I wake up and I battle
physics and I'll give you an example of
this so on the side of our rocket
there's a silver stripe now the reason
the silver stripe is because there's
avionics components in behind there we
needed to lower the emissivity of the
skin so we didn't cook the the
components from the sunlight so we paint
a silver stripe well unfortunately as
you are seeing through the Earth's
atmosphere you generate a lot of stated
static electricity and if you don't have
conductive paint then you basically seen
lightning bolts down to the earth so
even the silver paint has to be you know
tribo electrification certified and
implied and everything and don't even
get me started on the stickers they're a
whole nother story but the even the
simplest thing is always always you know
a real struggle now to the heart of any
launch vehicle is the engine this is our
rather third rocketing
and usually you measure rocket engines
in terms of time to manufacturer in
terms of sort of months or even you know
sometimes years doing really big engines
but if you're launching every 72 hours
as 10 engines per rocket then you know
you need to produce an engine very very
quickly so we needed to come up with a
whole new process and a whole new cycle
for the rocket engine so we came up with
a new cycle called the electric turbo
pump which we'll talk about in a moment
but we also managed to be able to 3d
print these rocket engines so that each
one of these engines is 3d printed out
of inconel superalloy and right now we
can put you know can print round about
one engine every 24 hours now the
electric turbo pump cycle is is a
totally different way to to pump
propellants under the rocket engine so
we carry about one megawatt where the
battery is on board and we have these
little electric turbo pumps or about the
size of a coke can not much bigger than
a coke can they spent at 42,000 rpm and
each one of those coke cans sized turbo
pumps produces about the same amount of
horsepower is your average family car
and we have 20 of them on the rocket so
you can see even just the simplest thing
like pumping propellants always pretty
much drives you insane this is an
electron it works
not only does it work once it seems to
work quite frequently which is very
handy when you've got a lot of customers
to put on all but so far we've put 25
satellites in orbit and the really cool
thing is we're able to do it very very
accurately in fact we insert the
satellites too with an inaccuracy of 1.4
kilometers and I guess if you're riding
in a cab 1.4 kilometers is not very
accurate
but in in kind of space terms and that
equates to around about 180 milliseconds
we travel 1.4 kilometers in about 180
milliseconds so it's actually quite hard
to do now what I want to talk about here
is space junk we've talked a lot about
you talked a lot about during this this
kind of talk about you know how we want
to launch really frequently every 72
hours and all the rest of it however I
don't want to go down in history as the
guy that put the most amount of space
junk in orbit and this is kind of the
industry's dirty little secret here what
most people don't realize that the
majority of space junk by mass is not
actually satellites it's did Rockets
because as you have seen to orbit you
have to share bits of the rocket in
order to get there with the Battle of
physics so I'm going to give a little
bit of orbital mechanics 101 here and
talk about how we go to orbit and how we
do it really really differently from
everybody else so the second stage
cruises along and then we separate off
the thing on the top called the kick
stage but we leave the second stage in
this highly elliptical orbit and at the
perigee of the orbital or the lowest
point it dips into the Earth's
atmosphere and basically burns back up
so now we're left with this little kick
stage which is that white thing on on
the corner of the screen and it's got
its own propulsion system and we use
that to raise the orbit and trim the
orbit and then deploy the spacecraft and
then because it's got its own engine we
put it into a retro all but put it back
into a highly elliptical orbit and
re-enter it into the Earth's atmosphere
and burn it back up and leave absolutely
nothing behind everybody else in the
industry is just downright filthy they
just leave their crap everywhere up
I want to tell you a little bit of a
story and this is going to going to date
me but I went to a school at the very
bottom of the South Island in New
Zealand tiny little school and we had a
computer not just similar to this one
and attached to that computer was a
little black box called a modem and
every Friday the class would gather
around the computer and we would send a
equivalent of an email to another school
in America that was lucky enough to have
the same kind of setup and we were it's
even we would receive an email back and
we thought that was just incredible
absolutely incredible now I often wonder
what would happen if I travel back in
time and I sat down with myself and I
explained all of the things that were
going to occur because of that little
black box connected to the computer I
mean you'd largely think that it would
be complete fantasy but the reality is
that is where we are right now with
space we're right on the verge of
democratizing space and we have
essentially sent our first email to
space when I give you some examples so
last year we flew a small satellite for
a bunch of high school students who had
built it and the high school students
were studying the atmosphere of Venus as
high school students launching their own
satellite another great example is
there's a number of really big programs
right now to place large constellations
or small satellites in orbit to deliver
Internet to every square millimeter on
the planet and for pretty much everybody
in this room that's just handy because
we can stream Netflix many we want but
if you think about the developing
countries of the world you've just
disseminated the entire knowledge of the
world to every single person in the
world and that's going to have a pretty
major effect thanks very much
[Applause]